hola yo no soy de león soy de jaén como
sé del sur o la sur
102 la espalda y bueno no os veo casi a
ninguno pero bueno os voy a contar un
poco mi historia aunque vosotros me
habéis anillo a vosotros no quiero ser
empresario quiero empezar algo quiero
hacer un proyecto volver a levantar la
mano para inspirarme cuantos queréis
hacer un proyecto con tres gustaría
pasar lo que hacéis ahora tener vuestra
propia empresa a ver que os vea
y el fondo sur que
bastantes no mucha gente muchos de
vosotros decís cómo puedo hacerlo si os
puedo compartir comunicar o animar o
iluminar como queráis que lo llamemos
con estos 89 minutos que voy a estar con
vosotros en este paso mire la verdad que
muy feliz yo en la primera dispositiva
que quería poneros es esta el miedo que
ha salido tantas veces hoy aquí el
vértigo la sensación de no tener nada
debajo y esa sensación yo creo que está
más relacionada
no solamente con la toma de decisión que
las tomas de decisiones son siempre muy
duras
todos queremos tomar las decisiones
mejores todos sabemos que tomar una
decisión significa renuncia significa
abandonar cosas significa decidir y esa
decisión no es lo más importante o lo
que más miedo nos da una vez que tenemos
esa decisión tomada que es habéis oído
que contaba enrique mi currículum y muy
cambiado para con saltamontes que estoy
aquí para allá y ha cambiado muchas
veces de pues de compañías y de puestos
quizá lo que más miedo me ha dado no ha
sido la toma de decisión que lo médicas
que lo piensas que eres los pros y los
colts que hay veces que tienes incluso
que escribirlo y os animo a que
escribáis muchas veces vuestros
pensamientos lo que me hace sentirme así
como un extra de positiva es lo que lo
que no conozco lo que me voy a encontrar
si voy a ser capaz de hacerlo si voy a
estar a la altura lo desconocido yo creo
que que se me da lo desconocido es quizá
lo que nos hace sentir esa sensación de
no tener el suelo por debajo esa
sensación de vértigo de miedo todos
tenemos vídeos en la vida
yo no estoy hablando del miedo de un ser
querido no sé hablando del miedo de
perder un padre o perder un hijo perder
a algo que realmente nos llena
emotivamente estoy hablando de una tema
de decisión como la que estamos hoy aquí
un trabajo una empresa ser empresario
dar de dar ese paso y tomar esa decisión
y yo un poco pues pues tomes la decisión
de dejar de ser ejecutiva y de trabajar
una compañía donde perdóname la
expresión se estaba muy caliente esta
era una compañía tan grande y una
compañía donde estás acompañado y donde
todo lo han solucionado y empezar tú
solo pues se sientes un poco bueno pues
que tienes que compaginar algún ambos
mundos que tienes que pasar de
de la confortabilidad de ese área de
confort que también se habla hoy aquí a
estar tú solo y la soledad es una de las
primeras cosas que tenéis que pensar los
empresarios que vais a vais a padecer o
que vais a tener que enfrentarnos es uno
de los grandes miedos y de las grandes
los as que tiene un empresario es la
soledad y la tenéis que gestionar porque
mejor tenéis un caballo o tenéis un
ordenador o tenéis un árbol como es en
mi caso yo tengo árboles o tenía árboles
alrededor que me acompañaban en ese
viaje pero tenía poco más la soledad del
que empieza la soledad que no sabe
hablando un poco de la soledad y del que
no sabe yo para mí una de las cosas que
más agradezco al empezar como empresaria
a empezar un proyecto desde cero es la
arrogancia de la ignorancia yo como era
una ignorante pensaba que lo podía ser
todo no era capaz de ver las
dificultades no vaya capaz de ver los
retos las grandes lagunas que yo tenía
de conocimiento del mercado de la
competencia de las vías para poder hacer
las cosas
yo veía al vaso siempre lleno yo en
beber que se me estaba vaciando el vaso
veía que el vaso de vino no es porque me
gusta mucho el vino que también estaba
estaba lleno y yo creo que también es un
aprendizaje que quería compartir con
vosotros no nunca perdáis esa esperanza
cuando empecéis un negocio de decir no
lo voy a conseguir muchas veces
consigues las cosas porque como no sabes
que es imposible o como esa es la
dificultad o lo loco o lo
el reto que significa lo haces esa
fuerza ese arrojo que hablamos esa
capacidad de empuje que te hace que tú
al final bueno pues veas el vaso medio
lleno y con todo esto me lance al mundo
trabajo con 52 países no disfruto tanto
como no hasta anterior amigo viajando
por el mundo porque viajo para vender
viajo para comprender los mercados pero
sí que es una gozada la apertura de
mente que nos da el viajar no dejéis de
contemplar como otras personas como
otros mundos como otras culturas ven de
forma distinta
eso es aprendizaje eso es crecer y eso
también es una forma de cultura que nos
hará más grandes todavía y a mí estos 52
países con los que trabajo y que procuro
visitar porque yo más o menos de unas
200 noches ahora de casa según mi marido
que está aquí no sé si lo dice porque
está encantado o porque me echa mucho de
menos pero según las 200 días o
doscientas noches me las paso fuera de
casa
bueno pues esas 200 noches me reportan
pues una satisfacción un conocimiento
de llevar mi país mi producto mi vida
fuera de mis fronteras pero al mismo
tiempo me traigo en la mochila en la
maleta aprendizajes como os comentaba
antes experiencias vivencias amigos
conocimientos sorpresas que hablamos
antes de la capacidad de sorprenderse ya
mis 55 años que ya sé que no los
aparento no me digáis nada a mis 55 años
todavía tengo esta capacidad de
sorprender de sorprenderme y decide y de
disfrutar y eso es parte de los 52
países en los que yo trabajo montañas
retos todos el himalaya os he puesto
aquí que los podemos superar si se puede
superar imaginaros en mi caso que encima
empecé a trabajar con mi hermano había
apuestas había porras hablé cuantos
meses dura vamos hubo gente que apostó
que no llegamos al año porque porque
claro es muy complicado trabajar con tu
padre trabajar con tu hermano trabajar
con tu sobrino trabajar tan yo lo que os
pone un poco puedo decir que la mejor
experiencia de todas es haber sido capaz
de trabajar con mi hermano con mi padre
con mi y con mi sobrino y con mi familia
y al mismo tiempo
de crear una familia dentro mi compañía
las personas que han hecho casi bueno mi
compañía o mi
[Música]
proyecto esas personas que me han
acompañado durante los últimos 15 años
son parte de mi familia son aquellos que
han hecho que esta compañía o que yo o
que lo que yo represento esté donde está
y yo creo que el agradecimiento el
respeto en la creación de equipo el
saber delegar también es algo que
tenemos que aprender cuando seáis
empresarios tenéis que crecer y pensar
que las personas que están a vuestro
lado son las que van a hacer que cada
vez eso sea más grande
cuáles son las claves para mí el respeto
la confianza
la capacidad de tratar a las personas
poniéndose en su lugar la empatía
el compartir el saber que un proyecto de
éxito nunca es algo individual un
proyecto de éxito siempre es algo que se
hace en conjunto en equipo nosotros mi
familia la gente que trabaja conmigo
somos un equipo por eso un placer estar
aquí con vosotros
[Aplausos]